what up space fam goals in here from
anime outpour to discuss the latest
crazy developments in the one piece
story and this chapter did not
disappoint
so make sure to stay tuned for that if
you enjoy seeing these one-piece reviews
on the channel and want to keep them
coming the best thing you can do is
smash that like button and share this
video with any cultured pirates that you
know
if you haven't be sure to subscribe this
is crucial hit that notification bell
and select
all or you will miss future one piece
videos plus our nakama is approaching 1
million pirates at this point so that's
pretty hyped too
lastly while you impatiently wait for
the next chapter to drop check out my
growing one piece playlist where you'll
find videos about the yonko warlord
supernovas
all the devil fruits and more link in
the description now without further ado
let's jump into its spoilers and
all this chapter is called somehow i
don't feel like we're losing
and that is definitely the vibe we've
been getting thus far i'm sure the
enormous undertaking of trying to take
down
to yonko and their crews seemed as close
to impossible as you can get for all of
us
especially when you take into account
luffy and kaido's first match
kaido seemed untouchable not to mention
all of his crew being thrown into the
mix
like king queen and so on but things
have been going almost too well up to
this point
kaido was hurt by the scabbards and
screamed out frankie has flexed on big
mom
marco showed up and seemingly teamed up
with pero sparrow
while the rest of the big mom pirates
might not even make it thanks to marco
suggesting that the threat of big mom's
crew might no longer be a thing
and much more and although it's all part
of making luffy's eventual victory
believable i think we all know that
things can't be this smooth from start
to finish
shonen's stories especially rely on
crazy twists often in the villain's
favor
to increase the intensity we can rest
assured that things will get worse
before they get better
and the better things are going right
now the more the situation will look bad
later on
there's a sort of buzzed feeling right
now for the good guys things seem to be
going
their way and they're excited as if
nothing can go wrong and if we've seen
enough shonen we know that that's when
we gotta be on our guard the most
so as we proceed yes let's enjoy the
epicness but also be prepared for some
sort of devastating setback or loss
in the near future we start this chapter
with big mom on the ground
taken down by frankie an absolutely epic
moment
showing no fear and absolute disrespect
to a yonko if that
ain't the crew member of the future
pirate king i don't know who is
people are hilariously shocked that
someone actually ran over big mob
and i absolutely love when characters
are fearless around the character who
would otherwise have people walking on
eggshells around them think of how luffy
punched the celestial dragon
when no one else would frankie had the
same energy at the end of the last
chapter as jinbei says they're in for a
treat and asks robin for help and nami
hugs frankie in gratitude luffy
acknowledges what frankie did
he's not surprised but just smiles
saying great work frankie as
expected and this is something i'm
noticing more and more in luffy
as a leader he's placing a lot of faith
in his crew and he has to do that that's
nowhere more clear than in situations
like this
where there are many powerful opponents
in addition to the main boss
and one man can't be expected to take on
the strongest creature in the world
plus other s-tier fighters at the same
time i really like that about one piece
much like in real life it continues to
foreground the importance of teamwork
even so
far into the story instead of just
having luffy become
strong enough to beat everyone so his
teammates become irrelevant in battle
and then we get the waited for moment
momonosuke reacting to yamato saying
she's his father
odin luffy lets them know that yamato is
on their side but they don't look too
convinced as
yamato runs towards them saying she's
odin and she will protect them
shinobi and momonosuke look back like
they're seeing the bad guy in a horror
film they continue to run while luffy
goes chasing after kinemon wanting to
face off against kaido
i can totally picture yamato screaming
after momonosuke come back and let your
father
love you such a bizarre and funny
situation will no doubt continue as we
move forward
big mom gets up looking evil and mad
cursing the straw hats
now they're gonna get it you may think
you can only mess with ayanko for so
long you may think
everyone else does and starts running
from big mom screaming for their lives
while hyogoro decides to find a toby
ropo
since these wasted extras just feel like
a waste of time for him
but no the straw hats are unfazed brook
waves hello to the yonko and frankie
asks how the old hag
likes his iron body before introducing
himself probably one of the most epic
introductions big mom has ever
experienced
nami speaks rationally warning frankie
to run away since she's a yonko
but there isn't much room for
rationality in the crew of the future
pirate king
frankie simply smiles brushing off the
idea by saying
and i quote aren't we gonna make our
captain the pirate king
end quote a goosebump inducing moment
and you can
already see how we're witnessing history
in the making and the legend of the
pirate king's crew members
is already in motion people will be
talking 100 years from now about how
frankie the pirate king
shipwright stood up to a yonko and even
talked down to her in this famous war
a living legend that's what frankie is
but as he's about to launch an attack
the numbers come in towering over people
frankie notices that they are the same
race as
oars and big mom is excited to see the
so-called failed ancient giants
from punk hazard and that seems to be a
recurring theme in kaido's crew the
revival of the ancient world
with its deadliest creature looked
another way though
you could also say that this symbolizes
how kaido is a fossil
and his time is over and he'll need to
make room for the new era
but anyways one number is straight up
holding usoff's team
and so frankie launches his radical beam
at him instead
despite the huge size of the numbers the
beam does send him flying back releasing
our
guys and all of a sudden people who were
saying oh it's a yonko
are now saying oh it's a laser beam
pretty epic how our straw hat crew can
shine even next to a yonko
as big mom's about to hit frankie jinbei
comes to the rescue
using fishman karate he flips the yonko
while robin uses her ability to make the
round
airborne yonko roll away not only are
the straw hats willing to upset the
yonko once they just
keep messing with her more and more and
in this arc more than any other
we are seeing that yonkos are not as
scary or untouchable
as they seem to be before imagine how
much
luffy's reputation will grow after the
world hears that his crew members were
playing around with big mom running her
over with motorcycles
and even passing her around like a beach
ball yes they're not stronger than big
mom
but that doesn't really matter here
they're brave enough to significantly
disrespect her
and invoke her anger which raises their
reputation in the world's eye while
diminishing big mom's
own as a sweating upset and spinning big
mom
threatens jinbe's life he simply says do
your worst
on a rhetorical and vibe level at least
some straw hats are already yonko level
being able to talk back to big mom
without blinking and that is a huge deal
illustrating that there is much more to
a story than who would win in a death
battle nico robin and jinbe smile
about what they did to big mom while
acknowledging that she will come back
angrier than ever i gotta admit that i
love the dynamic between these two
the bystanders who have become a pretty
huge joke by this point start shouting
that it's jinbei the former warlord
and first son of the sea literally
instead of fighting these guys are just
shocked by one thing after another
and you start to finally get why luffy
is so picky with his crew
and why he only has a few crew members
relatively speaking
what's the point of having guys like
this who are useless in a fight
all they would do is annoy you and cost
the crew extra money to feed
as frankie checks in on chopper and
usopp we get a pretty hilarious moment
as they get excited about fusing before
we jump to queen and his striking
moustache
queen is just enjoying a smoke in the
middle of the battle
when he sees luffy passing by zoro is
there too
while queen just keeps looking on
shocked zoro just agrees to tag along
with luffy who's going to fight kaido
and i can't help but love that this is
definitely one of the best bromances in
anime
and i always enjoy seeing these two
interact as luffy is going to take them
both
up queen turns into a dinosaur and
catches luffy in his mouth king is
present too with his flying fam
zorro says they're not going anywhere
with them around and luffy points out
that even the sky is heavily guarded
which is a nice touch
kaido straight up has land and sky
covered with his crew
quite the formidable force as the cool
fusion is underway to usopps
and chopper's amazement we get to see
sanji and he's pretty fine and
hilariously curses the durability
of his stinking suit it being so good
angers him but at this point everyone's
gotta use
everything they've got and i look
forward to seeing how sanji's gonna
contribute from here
being able to walk away from the attack
of the top all-star is pretty epic
as the number is taken down hyogoro sees
chopper and luffy coming down from the
sky
and enemies all around he still can't
help but smile and remark that it
doesn't feel like they're losing and
again it really doesn't
the vibe is very much positive uplifting
like
we're really doing this kind of
atmosphere we see
all the straw hats together looking epic
in one panel
a moment we gotta appreciate and i gotta
admit sanji probably looks the coolest
here
now in his classy clothes and smoking
together they prepared to help luffy get
to kaido
while sanji remarks about many flying
devil fruit users in the sky
and again luffy affirms that he's gonna
mop the floor with kaido
and that he trusts his crew to handle
the rest we got numbers we got queen and
king
and we got possible toby ropos that need
to be beat or at least distracted for
luffy to get the kaido we can be sure
that the next chapters are going to be
filled with some epic matchups and to me
this collective panel is pretty much
saying the real fight starts now
another epic chapter setting the
groundwork for the epic battles to come
let me know what you thought about this
one and any theories of what you expect
to happen next
if we're gonna get hit with a big loss
as i think we are who do you think might
be the victim
let me know if you did enjoy this review
and want to keep them coming the best
thing you could do is smash
that like button and share this video
with any cultured pirates that you know
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select
all or you will miss future one-piece
videos and while you impatiently wait
for the next chapter to drop
check out my growing one piece playlist
where you'll find videos about the yonko
warlords supernovas
all the different devil fruit users and
more link in the description
thanks again and until next time see us
space cowboys
[Music]
you